Yeah.
But let's talk about learning to code.
Right?
And,
and why are people being suspended for ta,
tweeting Hashtag learn to code?
Yup.
We did some research on this.
Yes,
we did some research on us.
Um,
so there was a situation,
I guess about a month ago or so where a number of journalists or receiving a
variety of tweets,
um,
some containing a learn to code,
some containing a bunch of other um,
coded language that was wishes of harm.
And these were thousands and thousands of tweets being directed at a handful of
journalists.
And we did some research and what we found was,
uh,
a number of the accounts that we're engaging in this behavior,
which is tweeting at the journalist with this either learn to code or things
like day of the rope and other coded language.
Uh,
we're actually ban of Asian accounts.
That means accounts that have been previously suspended.
And we also learned that there was a targeted campaign being organized off our
platform to abuse and harass these journalists.
That's not true.
Does he see,
here's the thing,
an activist who works for NBC wrote to that story.
And then lobbied to you,
you issued an official statement and then even the editor and chief of the daily
caller got a suspension for tweeting,
learned Dakota the day at the daily show.
So I have never talked to anybody from NBC about this issue.
Right,
right.
But there were no,
so they reported don't misrepresent me.
They report it at the narrative goes far and wide amongst your circles.
Then all of a sudden you're seeing a high profile conservatives tweeting a joke,
getting suspensions.
So again,
some of these tweets actually contained,
um,
death threats,
wishes of harm,
other coded language that we've seen to mean a death to journalists.
So it wasn't about just the learn to code,
it was about the context.
Queerness is not true.
That's just not true.
The editor in chief of the daily caller was suspended for tweeting nothing but
Hashtag learned to code,
sir.
Tim,
can I,
can I finish what I'm saying?
Yeah.
So we were looking at the context and what was happening is there were
journalists receiving hundreds of tweets.
So I'm had death threats,
some had wishes of harm,
some just learn to code.
And in that particular context we made a decision,
we consider this this type of behavior about dog piling,
which is when all of a sudden individuals are getting tons and tons of tweets at
them.
They feel very abused or harassed on the plan.
We pause this for super confusing.
For people who don't know the context,
the learn to code thing is in response to people saying that people that are
losing their jobs like coal miners and truck drivers and things like that could
learn to code.
This was,
it was almost like ingest initially or if it wasn't ingest initially it was so
poorly thought out as a suggestion that pizza started mocking it,
right?
Correct.
So that's correct.
The first stories that came out were simply like Ken miners learn to code or
there was no coal miners.
Right,
and they'll,
they'll hashtag learn to code is just a meme.
It's not even necessarily a conservative one that you will see more
conservatives using.
It was people are using it to mark how stupid.
The idea of taking a person who's on an educated as in their 50s who should our
learn some new
form of vocation.
And then someone says,
learn to code.
And so then other people,
when they're losing their job or when something's happening,
people would write,
learn to code because it's a meme.
Well,
not,
not even necessarily.
I would,
I would just characterize,
learn to code as a meme that represents the elitism of modern journalists and
how they target certain communities with disdain.
Okay.
So,
so to,
to make that point,
there are people who have been suspended for tweeting something.
Like,
I'm not too happy with how,
you know,
buzzfeed reported the story Hashtag learned to code,
right?
Making representation of these people are snooty elites who live in ivory
towers.
But uh,
but,
but again,
you know,
this is a meme that has nothing to do with harassment,
but you know,
it's,
some people might be harassing,
somebody might tweet it.
Why would we expect to see,
even still today,
I'm still getting messages from people with screenshots saying I've been
suspended for using a Hashtag and the editor in chief of the daily caller,
right?
He,
he,
he took,
he quote,
tweeted a video from the daily show with Hashtag learn to code and he got a
suspension for it.
So why,
why learn to code?
Why is that alone?
So
gracias.
And I don't think it is so egregious.
So is it just something that got stuck in an algorithm?
A No,
it was a,
again,
a specific set of issues that we were seeing,
um,
targeting a very specific set of journalists.
And it wasn't just the learn to code,
it was a couple of things going on.
A lot of the accounts tweeting learn to code word ban invaders,
which means that curiously been suspended.
A lot of the accounts had other language in them are of tweets that other
language like day of the brick day of the rope oven ready.
These are all coded meanings for violence against people,
right?
And so,
and the people who are receiving this,
we're receiving hundreds of these and what appeared to us to be a coordinated
harassment campaign.
And so we were trying to understand the context of what was going on and take
action on them.
Because again,
I don't know,
Joe,
if you've ever been the target of a dog piling event on Twitter,
but it is not particularly fun when thousands of people or hundreds of people
are tweeting at you and saying things.
And that's can be viewed as a form of harassment.
It's not about the individual tweet.
It is about the volume of things that are being directed at don't understand.
And so in that particular case we made the judgment call and it is a judgment
call to take down the tweets that were responding directly to these journalists
that were saying learn to code even if they didn't have a wish of harm
specifically attached to them because of what we viewed as coordinated attempt,
uh,
to harass them.
And again,
like I was saying,
some of the other signals and coded language and we were worried that learn to
code was taking on a different meaning in that particular context.
So but in and of itself though,
it still seems like there's alternative meanings to learn to code.
It still could be used as Tim was saying to mark a lip,
you know,
elite,
snooty speak truth to power.
Yes,
absolutely.
I agree
with you.
So it's really about the context of what was happening in that situation and all
those other things.
I think in a very
different situation we would not take action on that.
Okay.
But does not seem like your,
you're throwing a blanket over a very small issue.
I think learned to code in itself is very small.
The blanket is cast over racism,
the blanket is cast over this,
all,
all the other horrible things that are attached to it,
but the horrible things that are attached to it,
the real issue,
this learn to code thing is kind of a legitimate protest in people saying that
these minors should learn to code.
That's kind of preposterous.
The first articles weren't mean.
It was just,
it learned to code,
kind of identified.
You have these journalists who are so far removed from Middle America that they
think you can take a 50 year old man who's never used a computer before and put
them in the stories I think were legitimate.
Yes.
But the point more so it as it was a meme,
the Hashtag the idea of learning to code condenses this idea and it's easy to
communicate,
especially when you only have 280 characters that there is a class of
individual,
this country,
I think you mentioned on,
uh,
was it Sam Harris that the left,
the left liberal journalists only follow each other in the,
in the run up to the 25th,
2016 elections.
Yeah.
And so,
uh,
I mean I,
I still believe that to be true and I've worked in these offices.
It has changed that they've done this study.
Again,
the visualization and another is a lot more cross pollination.
But we'd,
what we saw is,
uh,
folks who are portraying on the left end of the spectrum mainly followed folks
on the left.
And folks on the right fold everyone what you were talking about earlier,
that there's is bubbles,
there's,
there's bubbles and we've helped create them and maintain them.
So,
so here's what ends up happening and this is one of the big problems that people
have with this story.
Particularly,
particularly you have a left wing activist who works for NBC News.
I'm not accusing you of having read the article.
He writes,
he,
he's,
he spends a like a day lobbying to Twitter saying,
guys,
you have to do this.
You have to make these changes.
The next day he writes a story saying that four Chan is organizing these,
these,
these harassment campaigns and death threats.
And while four Chan was doing threads about it,
you can't accuse fortune simply for talking about it cause you're right,
it was talking about it too as what's Twitter.
So then the next day he,
after he published his article,
now he's getting threats and then Twitter issues a statement saying we will take
action.
And to make matters worse.
When John Levine,
a writer for the rap,
got a statement from one of your spokespeople saying,
yes,
we are banning people for,
for saying learned to code.
A bunch of journalists came out and then lied.
I'd no idea why he's saying this is not true.
This is fake news.
Then a second statement was published by Twitter saying it's part of a
harassment campaign,
and so then the mainstream narrative becomes,
oh,
they're only banning people who are part of a harassment campaign,
but you,
you literally see legitimate high profile individuals getting suspensions for,
for joining in on a joke.
Oh,
they're there for sure.
Probably mistakes in there.
I don't think that any of us are claiming that we got that 100% right and
probably our team having a lack of context and to actually what's happening as
well and,
and we would fully admit we probably were way too aggressive when we first saw
this as well and made mistakes.
I hope this clarifies.
Then you have situations like this where you can see,
you know,
the,
this journalist,
I'm not going to name him,
but he routinely has very like left wing,
I don't want to use overtly esoteric words,
but uh,
intersectional dogmatic points of view,
right?
So this is considered me.
So like intersectional feminism is considered like a small ideology.
People refer to these groups as the regressive left or the identitarian left.
These are basically people who hold views that a person is judged based on the
color of their skin instead of the content of their character.
So you have the right wing version,
which is like the alt right,
the left wing version,
which is like,
um,
intersectional feminism is,
is,
is how simple referred to.
So you'll see people say things like,
you know,
when they typically,
when they rag on white men or when they say like white feminism,
these are,
these are signals that they hold these particular views and these things are
becoming more pervasive.
So what ends up happening is you have a journalist who clearly holds these
views.
I don't even wanna call him a journalist.
He writes extremely biased and out of context story,
Twitter takes action and response,
a seemingly and response.
Then we can look at what happens with Oliver Darcy at CNN.
He says,
you know,
the people at Seapak are the conservatives are gullible eating red meat from
grifters,
among other things,
disparaging comments about the right.
And he's the one who's primarily advocating for the removal of certain
individuals who you then remove.
And then when Kathy Griffin calls for Doxing,
that's fine.
When this guy calls for the death of these kids,
he gets it,
he gets a slap on the wrist.
And I look,
I understand the context matters,
but grains of sand to make a heat.
And eventually you have all of these stories piling up and people are asking you
why it only flows in one direction.
Cause I gotta I gotta be honest.
I'd imagine that calling for the death three times of any individual's abandon,
bull offense,
even without a warning,
he just get rid of him.
But it didn't happen.
Right.
We see,
we see these,
you know,
people say men aren't women though,
and they get a suspension.
We see people say the editor in chief of the daily caller,
maybe the best example hashtag learn to code a quoting the daily show and he
gets a suspension.
It's threatening death and inciting death is a suspension to it.
If it feels like it's only going in one direction.
Yeah.
I think we have a lot of work to do to explain more clearly when we're taking
action and why,
and certainly looking into,
um,
any mistakes we may have made.
And that's particularly particular situation.